n ame
パナソニック
ntp
野村證券肉知る
みなさんこれらの会社の共通項ってなんでしょうか
これらの会社は日本の大企業
そして東京オリンピックのスポンサー
そして最近 lgbt に関する取り組みがニュースになったら会社です
lgp
日本ではまだよく知られていない言葉なのでよく3匹と間違えられます
それ blp ですね
lgbt はレズビアンゲイバイセクシュアルトランスジェンダーの頭文字です
同性愛者や性同一性障害を抱える人など性的嗜好や政治に関する
マイノリティのことです私自身はレズビアンで lgbt に関する
企業向けのコンサルタントをしています
今日本の大企業は lgbt に強い関心を持っています
その理由の1つは2014年にオリンピック憲章が改正されたことです
オリンピック憲章第六所
差別禁止規定に性的指向が加わりました
これから開催都市は lgbt の人権にも配慮が求められるんです
だからスポンサー企業も lgbt に取り組んでいるんです
今日は lgbt と
スポーツの話をしたいと思います
ソースいやースポーツって本当にいいですよね
私自分でするのも見るのも大好きです
スポーツをすると健康になれる
ストレスが解消される
自分に自信が持てる
そして
信頼する仲間ができる
でも lc pt はスポーツから
疎外されがちなんです
皆さんも経験があると思いますが学校は同世代に関する
からかいや冗談があふれています女の子年
男の子として仲がいいと
怪しいと読みますよね
私は自分が合成者がず気付いたのは高校生の時でした
自分は他の人と違うおかしいんじゃないか
これ誰も言ってはいけない
業種の中で居場所がないように感じました
教室よりもっと居心地が悪かったのは
体育館や皇室です
私はずっと緊張していて最悪感も感じていました
他の人も体を切らやシャワーの時に見ないようにしていても誰かが私の大山目線から
何か気付くかもしれないイヤな思いをさせてしまうかもしれない
バスケットボールや柔道など相手の体に触れるスポーツも緊張しました
友達から気持ち悪いっ
言われるかもしれない
それは恐怖です
学校でソースの時に男の子が何かミスをすると学校の先生からお前はオカマかとヤジを
飛ばされることもあります
ゾンビの聞くたびにまるで自分の事を言われているようで体が壊れました
学校でましではスポーツをする場で
自分が同性が好きだな見えないと思いました
しかし lg pt わー
人口の数パーセントだと言われています
日本では5%や7%という調査結果もあります
5%って相当大きいですよねっていうことは当然私ポーツ選手にもいるはずです
2012年のロンドンオリンピック
日本選手団は293人
パラリンピックは130人でしたさあ皆さん
この中で lgbt は何だと思いますか
正解は
誰もカミングアウトしていませんでしたいやー確率から考えたら
いないはずはないん
日本ではまだ誰も言えないんです
カミングアウトしたらスキャンダルになる fire スポンサーが離れるかもしれ
ない
チームにいられなくなっ
でも世界は少しずつ変わってきています
ロンドンオリンピックでは20人以上のレズビアン系バイセクシャルのアスリートが
カミングアウトしていました
彼らの活躍を見て本当にわくわくしました
チームの一員として頑張っていて国の代表として応援される姿
それは自分たちがこうだったらいいなと思う姿だってからです
日本では lgbt を守る効率がありません
学校や職場で男らしくない男の子や
女らしくない女の子は熱情的にからかわれています
学校でいじめを経験している lg pc は7割です
職場で差別的言動を経験している人は
6割しますなので学校や職場からドロップアウトしがちです
そしてそれは貧困のハイリスクそうになります
うつを経験している人も非常に多い
自殺のリスク lg pt は一般の方の6倍です
私自身も3の場合で lgbt の仲間を何かを自殺で亡くしています
こんな経験をもうたくさんです
学校や職場で孤立している lgbt の仲間たち
スポーツも一緒にできないとしたら
悲しすぎます
lg 匹も社会を子もに来ていることを
スポーツを通じて伝えることはできないでしょうか
lgbt の t トランスジェンダーに関してはもう一つ大きなハードルがあります
それはほとんどのスポーツは男と女で分かれているということです
男性として生まれても女性として競技で第一がいます
逆に女性として生まれても男性として9件でたい人もいます
その場合は非常に厳しいホルモン治療など医学的な基準を満たさなければなりません
トランスジェンダーの中には男女どちらにも扱われたくない人だっています
そういう人はスポーツを諦めなければいけないんでしょうか
じゃ夏のオリンピックで
男女が分かれていない競技ってご存知ですか
手が挙がらないはい世界はバージュスだけです
パラリンピックは文書化
パラリンピックはテニスと自転車と射撃で
男女混合で競う種目がありますこれは障害の程度で分けているそうです
私はこれがヒントになるんじゃないかと思っています
男女で種目を分ける根拠として言われるのは
男性は女性より大きいから力が強いからだと言われています
本当にそうでしょうか
例えば筋力を測定するとだいたいい正規分布になります
女性の山男性の山
これをみるとたしかに平均値や中央値でみたら男性の方が強いというのは正しい
しかし中には多くの男性よりん
力の強い女性もいます奥の女性より力の弱い男性もいます
個人で見れぱ男女で分かれおけるのがフェアとは一概に言えないんじゃないでしょうか
今スポーツをソースに必要な力を数値化して特定する技術がどんどん進んでいます
例えばそのスポーツで必要な重要な筋力や技の熟練度などを数値化して総合的なクラス
分けができるようになったらどうでしょうか
使う用具の進化で補完できる部分もあると思います
例えば射撃アーチェリーなど進退的な接触の少ないスポーツからでも検討することは
できないでしょうか
トランスジェンダーも一緒にスポーツを楽しめるように検討すること
それはスポーツにおいてどんなルールがフェアなのかをもう一回考えるチャンスだと私
は思います
トランスジェンダーも含むみんなが楽しめるスポーツが増えればきっと余裕社会になる
はずです
最後に
人種差別と戦ったネルソンマンデラの言葉をご紹介したいと思います
彼は南アフリカでワールドカップが開催された時にこう語りました
スポーツには
世界を変える力がいい
今まで絶望しかなかった場所に
希望を灯すことができる
ロンドンオリンピックでは
プライドハウスが設けられましたグライドハウスというのはエール gbt な
アスリートやスタッフが集まってこれ選手村の近くに作るんですが集まって情報交換
できる場所のことです
私はこのプライドハウスを東京オリンピックパラリンピックでもぜひ作りたいと
持っていますグランドハウスで東京は lgbt を歓迎すると世界にメッセージを
出しましょう
世界中
数千万円いるはずの lgbt の若者たち
それぞれの世界で孤立して自殺を考えているかもしれない
子どもたち私は彼らに lg 武器が3とが活躍する姿を
見せたいんです
スポーツを lgbt も含むみんなのものに
ありがとうございました